i'm bill hemmer i'm janis dean i'm juan
williams and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday february 9th 2022
i'm dave anthony
several democratic-led states are
getting ready to lift some covet mask
mandates republicans say it's about time
and now we've got a whole you know
generation of little kids who are afraid
of air and think they're going to kill
grandma if they take their mask off and
but there's no science behind any of it
we speak with gop senator rand paul
and lisa brady brighter days for the u.s
travel industry may be just around the
corner this thing's a coiled springs can
come back a lot quicker than economists
predict economists are saying 2024 i'm
not buying it and not because i'm in the
industry i've just watched this before
when travel comes back and comes roaring
back and i'm guy benson i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
more americans will soon be unmasked
again we're not going to manage covet to
zero we have to learn how to live with
covet governor phil murphy planning to
lift new jersey's mass mandate next
month we can responsibly take this step
given the continuing drop in new cases
and hospitalizations other democrat-led
states will do the same california and
oregon pennsylvania and delaware and
connecticut where governor ned lamont
says i think this is something we've
earned connecticut we've earned it local
officials and school districts still can
require masks in those states but
republicans think it's a positive step
you know it's about time the science has
been there for a long time that
particularly the cloth mask don't work
gop senator rand paul is from kentucky
in fact i really don't think many of the
government mandates or any of the
government mandates really changed the
course of this disease the only thing
that we've done that has helped slow the
disease down has been vaccination
and also natural immunity and both of
those are gradually allowing us to
develop immunity but really masks
plexiglass you know the separation none
of those things probably worked in fact
if you look at the
timeline of when the mandates were put
in place there's no real evidence that
there was a change or decline in the
incidence of the disease if you look at
countries like sweden that haven't had
their school kids in masks no kids out
of 1.8 million kids no kids died in
sweden and there wasn't an enhanced or
increased incidence of disease among the
teachers either so it's about time we
get rid of the mass mandates we need to
get them off the planes off the kids we
need to get back to normal
but it's going to be difficult because
local jurisdictions do in some states
have the say
we are seeing that fight go on in
virginia over and over in courts
local districts defying orders this is
not going to go away soon
i think you're going to find though that
parents even parents that are
independent or democrat or tired of
having their kids faces covered
you're going to find kids and parents
who have kids who have special needs
people who have hearing disabilities etc
these parents are going to rally and
keep pushing and they're unhappy
and i hope these parents will show up at
school board meetings that will elect
new people school boards and that
ultimately this may be something that
actually drives people more towards the
freedom-loving nature of the republican
party maybe people who were democrats
are going to say why am i part of a
party that won't let my kid you know
breathe based on something that's not
scientific doesn't seem to protect them
but still this is you know
it's not completely permeated throughout
society yet there's still some people
and now we've got a whole you know
generation of little kids are afraid of
air and think they're going to kill
grandma if they take their mask off and
but there's no science behind any of it
the vast majority of people now have
been infected or vaccinated and there's
really no reason to be doing these
things so hopefully common sense will
win out of the end you know you had
mentioned the senator the vaccination is
helping along with natural immunity but
democrats said well see mandates work
like the mayor in new york city to bill
de blasio the ex-mayor now saying that
his mandates worked he got more people
vaccinated because of that and the
president has been trying to do the same
thing
before there were any vaccine mandates
if you look at the cdc numbers on
vaccination it was an enormous voluntary
success
97 of people over age 65 got vaccinated
voluntarily and they didn't have to be
mandated they looked at the data and
said
this looks like a disease that kills
older people i think to help take a
vaccine and most people did it
voluntarily the mandates are to get
people who don't think it's in today to
their benefit to get vaccinated to force
them to fire people to fire doctors and
nurses and really i have a lot of
sympathy for doctors and nurses who
worked for over a year taking care of
coca patients many of them got it some
doctors and nurses died but the vast
majority recovered and now have immunity
that equals or exceeds a vaccine and i
just think it's an awful authoritarian
notion to say you're going to fire those
people
what do you tell people though who still
refuse and don't want to get the vaccine
what i would do is if you're not
vaccinated ask your doctor if you can be
tested for immunity to find out if
you've had it if you've had the disease
i frankly think unless you're an
extraordinary high risk you don't need
any vaccine at all i i had the disease
naturally and i chose not to get
vaccinated if i were 10 years older or
had a couple comorbidities i might have
taken the vaccine though i'm not adamant
about that but if you take a test and
you don't have any antibodies you
haven't been vaccinated and you have no
antibodies showing prior infection i
think it's a reasonable thing to think
consider being vaccinated particularly
if you're over probably 55 and
overweight at almost any age so i think
if you're honest with people and told
them yes previous infection works but
you haven't had a previous infection i
think there is a certain amount of
people that will but if you've been
lying the whole time and saying previous
infection does nothing and you've been
advocating for cloth masks that don't
work and you've basically been dr falchi
and dishonest about just everything
those people you won't get them back
yeah you know they're not going to come
back and get vaccinated because they now
think because you're willing to lie on a
few things that probably you're lying
about everything a month ago he and dr
anthony fauci sparred yet again at
another senate hearing with senator paul
accusing the bythen advisor of trying to
silence scientists on the covet lab leak
theory you conspire and i quote here
directly from the email to create a
quick and devastating published takedown
of three prominent epidemiologists as
usual senator you are incorrect almost
everything well no you deny you deny but
the emails tell the truth of this no
then senator paul took aim at fauci's
covent guidance more people have died
now under president biden under
president trump you are the one
responsible you are the architect you
are the lead architect for the response
from the government you personally
attacked me and with absolutely not a
shred of evidence of anything you say
and dr fauci said that kindles the
crazies out there and i have life that
threats upon my life harassment of my
family alleging senator paul's motive
for it all is to raise money for himself
so you are making a catastrophic
epidemic for your political gain back
and forth they went for almost nine
minutes the interesting thing is is that
the question i asked him
was do do you think it's appropriate to
use your 420 000 office to attack other
scientists say i asked him about
personal attacks he turned it around by
not answering the question and then
making a personal attack and are we
raising money on it absolutely because
we want the band-aid stand we want him
gone we want the origin to be
investigated but the democrats aren't
doing it so it is about politics if if
republicans take over the senate i'll be
chairman of a committee and i've pledged
to people that i will investigate falchi
i'll investigate the origins of the
virus i'll subpoena all the records and
we're going to have hearings about
whether the government should be funding
uh research that creates viruses that
don't exist in nature
that could cause pandemics and we're
going to have that discussion the
democrats have refused so it is
political and frankly i think he uh far
as saying oh he's responsible for death
threats that is
really a personal attack that's
inappropriate i was at the ball field
when steve scalise almost died i had a
staffer shot five feet from me and for
him to say oh
you know not one of us said it was
bernie sanders fault bernie sanders uh
the guy was a bernie sanders supporter
that shot up the ball field so it's kind
of ridiculous to say that the other
thing is the week that he's complaining
about a death threat which i i don't
want anybody to hurt him i had 34 death
threats so who's responsible is he
responsible for those i mean it's kind
of really really a juvenile argument to
try to say someone's responsible for
crazy people in our in our society the
origin you've talked about where this
virus came from in china are you
convinced that it came out of the lab
i started out very skeptical of it and
it took me probably nine months nicholas
wade's article and some others uh to
come to the conclusion that yes it is
i think it's 90 10 i uh 90 chance that
it came from the lab 10 chance that it
didn't they they looked at 80 000
animals in those wet markets none of
them had covet they tested 80 000
animals that's a big sample
they also tested the blood of 9 000
uh people from china who had flu-like
symptoms in 2019
if it came gradually from animals you'd
expect a few of those people to be
positive for um covet none of them had
covet so
you take covet from humans and then you
try to infect bats with it it doesn't
infect them very well there's a lot of
indications that looks like this was
designed to infect humans so yeah
there's a lot of evidence pointing
towards the lab and the reason we need
to know it's not just about blame it's
not just about fauci's support for gain
of function or his support for this lab
it's about making sure this doesn't
happen again
um about a month ago in the washington
post kevin espelt who's a professor at
mit and not a partisan that i know of
wrote and said that this type of
research could threaten civilization
it's a gamble that civilization
should not should not take and so i
think there are some objective minds and
when we're in charge i'm going to bring
in those scientists and we're going to
have a very thorough vetting of gain of
function and we're going to come up with
uh new rules to put in place about this
type of research with government money i
want to get back to the coveted mandates
there's a big protest north of the
border you're probably following this
the freedom truck convoy snarling
traffic at some border crossings it's
blocked streets in the canadian capital
of ottawa i want you to hear what the
mayor jim watson said he said people are
terrified and they've now been subjected
to the non-stop honking of large trucks
for nine days which is tantamount to
psychological warfare and prime minister
justin trudeau says that they're
blockading our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens
daily lives
it has to stop what's your reaction to
all that
i would argue that the government is
blockading trade blockading travel
blockading commerce with all the crazy
unscientific rules and regulations and
mandates that put in place so my heart
is with the truckers i saw somebody on
twitter this morning who said i'd rather
be ruled by a bunch of truckers and
farmers than academics and and
journalists and i'm with him i mean
common people have common sense
and they want to be left alone there's
no evidence that any of these mandates
have changed the course of the disease
but people want their freedom back and
god love them i i think it's a great
spontaneous thing that's arisen i'm for
american truckers doing the same i'm for
people boycotting new york city and
california don't go to these places that
hate freedom and hate you and hate
republicans we should avoid you know why
live there move to florida move to texas
move to kentucky move somewhere else but
you know and that's what's happening
people are fleeing and looking for
freedom look even aoc can't go out and
have a good time in new york city she's
got to go to florida looking for a good
time
you're often you know this you're
attacked on the left you can google see
all the people say things about you
conspiracy theorists spreading false
information
what do you say what do you try to
respond to that
you know there's not one uh position
that i've taken that is not backed by
peer-reviewed uh science
you know i have a background in science
went to medical school have published in
peer review uh articles in journals and
what you find if you go to a scientific
convention
is that you do you have to defend your
work people will will say your sample
size was too small they'll say you had
selection bias in your sample size
they'll say you ignored this and that
but that's how science gets better
through criticism what's worrisome about
the left is they don't want to hear any
criticism the left wants to stifle
debate and they say their way to the
highway
and uh a great irony that you know the
left that once defended the first
amendment now wants to uh you know put
the kibosh on free speech it's it is
alarming shalom everyone senator rand
paul republican from kentucky we
appreciate your time thanks for having
me
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
people aren't just longing for a return
to normalcy they're planning for it if
travel is an indicator one survey taken
in mid-january by research firm
longwoods international finds 91 of
respondents who traveled before the
pandemic have travel plans in the next
six months and one quarter surveyed said
their travel decision is no longer
influenced by the pandemic over the past
two years we've seen what happens when
the world stops traveling tori emerson
barnes executive vice president of the
u.s travel association highlighting the
emotional and economic impacts at the
group's annual update on the state of
the u.s travel industry held recently by
webcast and she tells fox business we've
lost over 700 billion dollars in in
spending here in the us
by not having international travel and
that's just really really significant
kobit's omicron surge didn't really hit
its stride until after christmas but by
then the variant had already created a
stressful testing ordeal for many
travelers still the holiday season
stayed busy and in the cruise industry
bookings are running well into next year
i think we're actually beginning to see
the travel industry the rebound roger
dow is the u.s travel association
president and ceo domestic leisure is
going to be very strong and the key is
to bring back business and professional
meetings and events and all the signs
we're seeing with omicron uh the case
counts going down masks changing
i think we're going to be ready for a
good summer a decent spring and then i
think fall we'll start seeing things
come back very very strong
i have to imagine that the omicron surge
was especially deflating for the travel
industry because things had started to
pick up last summer right and then all
of a sudden
this new huge wave later in the year it
is there concern within the industry
that that could happen again
there's always concern we thought we
were getting to the tail end of delta
and then when omicron reared its head it
was really a problem with the one step
forward two steps backwards and it
really put a link pink and you know
international travel and all that but
the good news is if there's good news in
these kind of things is we're seeing
it's very mild yes it's very
transmissible but the numbers the case
counts the hospitalizations all those
are going negative and everything i know
about diseases i'm not a doctor but
everything i know is they mutate mutate
mutate and each mutation gets a little
weaker and if that follows the case of
other viruses i think we're going to
start soon putting this behind us
is there optimism
across the board where maybe last summer
it was still more hesitant um in terms
of the spectrum of the travel industry
from airlines to hotels vacation rental
homes
um that this summer could be you know
more of a turning point
track uh sentiment data uh with about
six or seven different sources and
they're all
the past
month and a half saying the same thing
and that is eighty percent of americans
say they're going to plan a trip in the
next six months sixty percent of
americans two-thirds are basically
saying they understand this is something
that is uh trailing off that they're
gonna live with so i think looking
forward this is gonna be a very strong
summer because the other thing is people
are telling us they are just sick and
tired of not seeing their loved ones
their friends and traveling and i think
this thing's a coiled spring that's
going to come back a lot quicker than
economists predict economists are saying
2024 i'm not buying it and not because
i'm in the industry i've just watched
this before when travel comes back it
comes roaring back
where do we stand right now in terms of
covert related travel restrictions in
the us i know internationally some
countries have already pulled back on
testing requirements after a really
hectic and frustrating holiday season
for a lot of travelers especially air
travelers
is it easier to travel now in terms of
covert rules than it was you know just a
few months ago at least in terms of air
travel it's getting easier now let's
let's break it down some pieces domestic
air travel last year we had over 500
million people americans got on and off
plane
and we can't find traces back to kovic
so the airplane's probably one of the
safest places to be to tell you the
truth safer than the grocery store so
people know that the thing that is also
helping us in international travel is as
these countries uk portugal greece now
are all taking back the need for
pre-testing before you get on a flight
and the reason that's a problem is
people are concerned that they might get
a positive or false positive and the day
before their trip have to cancel it lose
money have to rebook and all that so
removing that testing requirement i
expect many countries to start following
it always goes this way and
with all due respect to the cdc
we've had several times where we've
talked about thanksgiving travel or
holiday travel and we had one time the
cdc came out two hours before a press
conference and said do not travel
the next day the number of bookings went
up uh around america i think with all
due respect to the cdc americans are
basically saying we've heard so many
conflicting things we're going to follow
the data what we hear from our friends
what we hear from people that have been
traveling and we're going to follow that
i know that cruising
has had its own
cova journey to say the very least
now that more cruise lines are back
there there have been a few incidents of
large outbreaks but overall
how is it going is the cruise industry
fully back yet
the cruise industry has been coming back
and was looking for it still looking
forward to a great 2022.
again
most recently the cdc changed the
guidelines on the cruise industry
not that much based on data i mean there
have been some cruise ships where i know
one cruise ship had 30 cases 26 for
employees four were passengers not one
went to the hospital
and so you're getting these mild cases
in the cruise industry has been a
squeaky clean industry before because
they've had to be but even more so now
and they test people before they get on
board they've got to have proof of
vaccine and the other thing that's
happening with cruises is their bookings
are monstrous all the people that didn't
go on cruises the past two years have
rebooked and people want to go so the
monstrous bookings they just have to get
through the schizophrenia that's going
on with cdc and the cruise industry
what does the travel industry
want going forward and i know it's a
really broad question because there's so
many different facets of the travel
industry but do you think that you know
coveted restrictions of any kind
should remain in place depending on the
type of travel well i think you i think
you peel the onion you start bringing
things back slowly and you peel this
onion back and you feel this restriction
the biggest problem the travel industry
has is not only in the u.s but globally
and you hit the nail on the head earlier
is inconsistency each place i go
i have to end up calling and finding out
what is the procedure do i have to wear
a mask do i have to show proof of
vaccination so one of the biggest things
we need for the government is to across
the board to get consistent the other
thing we need is there's something
that's inside baseball perhaps called
brand usa and it's the it's the group
that promotes america outside america
and they're funded by tourists well the
past two years they haven't gotten any
funding so we have a bill with the
government called the uh restore brand
usa act and and that group has 200
million dollars each year to spend to
bring travelers the united states and
it's one of the biggest things we can do
so hopefully we'll get a bill passed
that they'll restore brand usa's funding
temporarily that's all we want is just
temporarily because that's the fastest
way to bring business and jobs back to
the united states i know one idea to
help get business travel moving again
was a tax credit for organizers and
sponsors of things like trade shows and
conventions
is that gaining any traction in
washington
yes it is there's several bills that we
have that attach to here's the the crazy
thing if if you go to a baseball game
and you can deduct the tickets as a
business expense if you buy someone a
hot dog you can't deduct the hot dog and
just makes it it's irrational and so
we're looking for again to restore that
ability for entertainment expenses for
people when they travel so hopefully
that'll see the light of the day you
know we don't want to be greedy but we
want to be able to take these businesses
but so
badly harmed and get the government to
help get them back on their feet because
they didn't cause this it was the
restrictions were put on them and i
think we have a dual role to help them
get back because business travel and
professional meetings events
are probably about 20 of the trips but
they represent about 40 to 50 percent of
the revenue in other words business
travelers spend more so it's very
important to bring them back to put it
in perspective business travel in the
past year was probably down 70 percent
we're projecting hopefully it'll be back
this year to about 75 percent or three
quarters what it was in 2019
the challenge with business travel are
two or three things
one is the corporate finance cfo is
saying look at all the money we made
during covet and our people didn't
travel maybe we shouldn't have them
travel just keep making money
you've got the general counsel saying
well if we don't tell them to travel
they'll never sue us if they got sick on
the road and then you've got their
friends and relatives saying widow mary
takes a trip and she comes back okay
then you take the trip
so there are three headwinds that we
have to overcome
what is all this done for the travel
insurance
business like are a lot more people
buying it now because of all the
uncertainty and they're afraid they
might test positive while they're on a
trip and things like that it's actually
been good for the travel insurance
business but the high majority of travel
insurance is very much with
international travel
and and actually there's very strict
things that how you can really collect
it's not just if you decided not to take
the trip you can't but the other thing
that has actually been helpful the
traveler and perhaps not to the travel
insurance folks is the airlines and
hotels have gotten extremely flexible
gone are the penalties and the inability
to rebook airlines are letting you
rebook your travel hotels but i always
tell people make sure you know when you
book a hotel what their policy is if you
have to cancel or change but right now
there's great flexibility so people
aren't as worried about having to cancel
or change their trips as they were
several years ago
do you have any other advice for people
who are booking
spring and summer
vacations right now whether it's
airlines or cruises or just vacation
rentals i mean
is there sort of a
big picture that you want them to bear
in mind that's you know helpful to the
industry
yeah and again not because i'm in the
industry but my message is booked now as
travel comes back as you know what
happens is demand increases prices go up
so and with the flexibility of changing
so one book now the second thing if i
were looking to go to a broadway player
or go to a city i would do that now
because the people that are most having
the biggest problems are the inner city
big convention hotels and all that there
are bargains in new york chicago
washington that you'll never see again
short term so i say hey take a look at
those cities and book travel there and
the last thing is know before you go and
just like i do before every trip even
though i'm in the business i have my
assistant reach out and say what are the
protocols what do i have to know for
instance i went to new york city two
weeks ago and
i had to show my vaccination card and my
driver's license to get a meal at a
delicatessen so but you should know that
in advance just in case you don't think
to bring your vaccination guard with you
roger dow president and ceo of the u.s
travel association thanks so much for
joining us always a pleasure thanks lisa
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson
what's on your mind i'm a sports fan and
i really enjoy the olympic games
particularly the winter olympics because
i love hockey but this year i am not
watching the winter games in beijing
because they're being hosted by a
genocidal regime in the last few years
the chinese communist party has carried
out a genocide against ethnic and
religious minorities they have choked
the life out of democracy in hong kong
in violation of international law
they've covered up and lied about the
origins of a virus that started in china
that has killed millions of people
around the world and that's all on top
of their generalized baseline of
wrongdoing and abuses ranging from human
rights to intellectual property theft
china should never have been awarded
these games in the first place and they
certainly should not have been able to
keep the games in the face of their
egregious and escalating misconduct over
the last two years i hope our american
athletes excel while the chinese
communist party is shamed this is guy
benson host of the guy benson show
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown rundown stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes